yo yo what up man you rocking with trade
the truth AKA King truth and if you
don't know I'm telling you to stop what
you're doing and tune in go check me out
real soon on the bootleg K
podcast yo bootleg C podcast bootleg C
show special guest is here my guy Trey
the truth what up though the new album
is coming out next week yeah October
20th Stuck In Motion Stuck In Motion I
just saw um this the first video coming
out with Larry June yeah just came
dropped just dropped shout out to Larry
June man yeah shout out bro man yeah um
you know I do feel like uh you have been
like such a
Powerhouse in hipop for so long
especially when it comes to just
like doing it the Texas way independent
you know what I'm saying and it feels
like the last like two or three years
you finally for whatever reason just
started to kind of get your flowers I
think I just saw you on Joe Rogan so if
my feel if someone's on Joe Rogan it's
the biggest plat in the world shout out
Joe that's my brother man but do you
feel that like do you feel like finally
like you've always had your respect
within hip hop you've always had your
respect within obviously the whole South
um trade a has been just a movie for how
many years now over a decade yeah 15
years but do you feel like recently you
finally kind of started to get
recognized from like more of The
Gatekeepers more of like the you had a
pretty uphill battle you know especially
coming out of where you're and and I'm
I'm still having that battle but um I
thank God just he he opening the lane
for me but I think he doing it at his
pace
so how big I'm going to get I ain't I
haven't got there yet but he I'm on the
uphill climb still right now and he you
know he's doing different things to let
me know it's not a point of giving up
it's not an option just like little
things happen that keep you going like
you know what I'm on the right Mission
like I got to keep going yeah definitely
man and um you know it's just all kind
of crazy things happening left and right
in a good way you know so I'm grateful
man um how did you end up on the Rogan
podcast like how like who connected that
um he's had Jake Prince on he's had
Willie D on he's I mean obviously he's a
hip-hop guy he yeah Joe Joe's you know
that's family that's like my brother but
you know I'm tied in with the UFC okay
so you know Dana's my that me and Dana
White real close and just the whole
staff oh you guys talked about that too
like the uh what's the big the big
fighter I'm not a big UFC you guys Beast
yeah you guys had him yeah the Beast um
Dustin puer um Kevin Holland um man it's
so it's so many of them I'm tied into
but you know I have an actual license
deal with UFC cuz you know we have UFC
bump boxes you listen you got everything
bump boxes people win the Super Bowl
they got a bump box dbo Samuels running
around with a bump box everybody's got
listen if people don't understand like
and and I I I'm not being paid to say
this not cuz you're here here I tell
this to people all of the time do not
waste your [__] money on any of these
three4 $500 [__] Bluetooth
speakers the bump box is crazy yeah it
is crazy and we man you know we just
released a new version which is the
remix that um look like the cassette
tape yeah um you just showed me it looks
crazy I think the one I have is called a
flare eight yeah yeah yeah we still got
all those we got we got the um um we got
so many different ones you know we did
the deal with the gronowski so we got
Shaker cups that got the speakers on
them now too like a cup yeah the Shaker
cups yeah like mhm um you know our
headphones coming um you familiar what a
cornhole is yeah cornhole yeah so you
know any cornhole that has a speaker on
it we own the rights to it so we have a
new cornhole bump boxes so one of my
best friends is best friend well his one
of his best friends is the guy from SWAT
the beautiful uh baldheaded man what's
his name you know his name Shamar Shamar
Moore yeah and he's a part of the
cornhole League oh yeah I'm have toar MO
is yeah I I we don't know each other but
I'll find them and make sure we get no
so he has like um in his backyard ESPN
oo or whatever ESPN number will
broadcast the cornhole competition but
it's ESPN um they like he has a whole
like real cornhole like Arena in his
backyard you you know somebody who know
him yeah so put me with him yeah we'll
FaceTime him right now yeah I'll show
you how it work yeah cornhole [__] is
booming right now you need to get a hold
of you know what else is popping right
now that everybody's doing and I don't
know why but have you heard of pickle
ball no pickle ball is like the new
[__] way like overweight dudes who
like don't want to work out work out cuz
they're like yo it's
fun and I burn calories but it's not
like you know running in place pickle
ball uh what is
that I just know there's a paddle and I
know
that there's a rapper who owns a team
smaller version tennis
yeah Katie is a part owner of the team
in New York there's a pickle ball uh
League that just started and Kevin
Durant I think is one of the owners no
he is one of the owners of the uh oh yes
I love my bro K yeah you got to get
locked in I wonder like you always hear
about the Joe Rogan Spike you go on the
show do you see spikes in analytics
followers music goes up everything goes
up or or I I haven't even I ain't really
paid attention cuz I've been moving on
yeah you've been moving nonstop yeah
you're in album mode but I what I will
say
is different people who ain't who ain't
necessarily familiar with my music and
other stuff when they see me they like
man I just seen you on Joe Rogan uh
podcast yeah you know what I'm saying so
definitely a blessing but I know one
time Joe posted the bump box and I know
that day alone was with some crazy
numbers sold yeah yeah yeah for sure for
sure man that shit's dope congrats on B
has anybody tried to come in uh buy you
guys out yet like a bigger company uh
you know they have but we work so much
now like we why would would you do it
yeah and if we do it's going to have to
make sense like it's going to have to be
like apple or something crazy yeah it it
have to be something crazy and I would
still be tied into it you because we
built that from yeah you guys have Sweat
Equity but you also have like personal
Equity into the company yeah do you guys
still have the store in Riverside uh
there was that you guys had a like a
flagship store yeah I'm not I'm not sure
cuz you know we had a course we had the
one in Houston and the Galleria but it
it got to the point we don't even need
the stores like it's online so crazy you
know why have the brick and mortar if
you don't need it yeah yeah but it was
dope to to do you know just to be able
to do that and um but right now it's
just it's going like if you look in the
Barbie movie we in there yeah I saw that
yeah you so we just we're a little bit
everywhere man did you think like
obviously you believed in bump boox but
it's crazy because it's like I remember
I used to always just associate bump box
with you cuz that's how I found out
about it right but it's transcended it
and it's so like you said it's in the
biggest movie ever yeah yeah um like did
you ever have any idea would get this
big honestly no you know it's still it's
still excitement there that that we
growing like when my you know we had the
headphones the waves that came out and
now we got the inir the in ear
headphones that's about to drop too hey
whatever headphone company you were
involved with I still have those
headphones yeah that was with us oh that
was them okay I still have those but now
we got the in ones and they
blel yeah yeah everything man oh yeah
you guys are we going we going to crush
it for sure um uh we got something
called a slap stick to
and like you can put it on anything
metal it'll it'll stick to it and um
it's a Bluetooth radio loud as hell you
know what I'm saying like we got magnet
you just slap it places like if you're
like if you're in a shop if you're
working on cars yep show
any anything metal yeah it's waterproof
uh I would say for the most part yeah
yeah yeah it's waterproof enough yeah
yeah for sure sick who old you got on
this new album um I really didn't do
features man I I had first class with
Larry June I have uh first class with
Larry June I have swear I'm with Tia and
my nephew Nico but other than that it's
just strictly me man I hate to do this
cuz my daughter callings do you think
man hey truth I'm doing an interview
right now what's wrong
baby okay soon as I get done I'mma come
get you
okay you hear me yeah all right love you
and then you is that your daughter that
lives out here yeah yeah yeah she just
moved to um she in she in Vegas now but
yeah she saving tax
money she here actually she here now I
just flew her here cuz you know I say
you don't have to worry about that in
Texas though yeah yeah St you know she a
Texas baby she born though um TI you
said l t yeah my nephew Nico other than
that it's strictly me um I wanted this
tape this tape is just kind of like the
the reintro to me cuz you got to realize
for years I ain't really been able to
just put out consistent music or album
because you may have somebody getting
killed by police so you may have a
natural disaster and you know when it
come to that I'm focused on the people
you know what I'm saying so I wasn't
able so this is the first one to kind of
get me back in the okay he's still on it
you know what I'm saying cuz now when
I'm moving around I got so many
relationships people overly excited you
know what I'm saying like and also a lot
of people are are there's a whole new
wave of people who associate who don't
really associate you with being a rapper
right right that's they look at you as a
businessman they look at you as somebody
who gives back who's helping people
during the hurricane somebody who's you
know just tied in in so many different
ways culturally that it's like hey also
I do this at a high level right so now
um this album I wanted it to be just
more of me just a good vibe nothing
crazy just straight good vibe music that
people can relate to from all walks of
life all Jas you know all A's brackets
and after that then I'm I'm going come
in and start putting press so um I want
to know how uh cuz right now two of the
most hottest rappers period are from
your region dbab and that Mexican OT
yeah yeah both of them doing their thing
both of them are doing their thing I was
about to say how much are you kind of
paying attention to like what they're
doing cuz uh man OT just sold out a show
in La he just finished his first
headline of tour and yeah yeah you know
you know I'm definitely familiar with
them man you know I I always Embrace
people early before the stuff start
really jumping off so it was always love
man you know I'm one of the people man I
salute congratulate you know just really
I stand behind just our city anyway
right especially you know I love
watching some of the younger generation
go to do their thing you know what I'm
saying to have their shot cuz everybody
had their shot it's no point of watching
certain people hog it like Blossom for
the Nick so it's them you know um I'm
going to be introducing the world to the
rejects which is a bunch of Street caps
from the city that have their own fan
base that make authentic music that I
feel need to be showed to the world and
displayed so the rejects coming and you
course you know that's me you have big
Tony Cal Wayne
ski taste Jack boy 30
ways um L The
Savage Millie
bucks uh fast
money um trying not to forget anybody I
be my mind be so so all over man but uh
definitely got to check for all them
that tape going to be something cuz
I'm that sounds like a massive like that
sounds like more like a collective like
the wuang clan kind of you know yeah
yeah it's definitely it's definitely
interesting man they first single going
to come out called the tension and it
may release real soon you know what I'm
saying they already got the visual shot
for that um I mean we just uh Jack boy
yeah we just we working man everybody
doing their thing yeah I think it's
refreshing too because I do feel like no
matter like you know we always think of
like the puke H the peak uh htown kind
of like you know 05
0304 you know Mike Jones Paul Wall uh
swisser house um Slim Thug yourself yeah
what I like about the new [__] I'm
hearing is it sounds very Texas and
obviously Travis has put out a lot of
records that sound very Texas and paid a
lot of homage to to htown but I feel
like it's it's just dope to kind of see
like these dudes making like
Unapologetic Texas Music and it work on
like a big level too so the reason it
works right Texas support is Texas
support you never even really got to
leave Texas to make CU it's so it's
right if anyone's ever driven through
Texas it's crazy yeah definitely it
never ends yeah so you got you got that
and
um when you have that and a foundation
built around it it trickers in the other
markets and you know they they trying to
feel like oh what's that what's what's
what's that child Jam M and then they
get on it then they go put people on it
so it works man there's nothing wrong
with staying true to your roots you know
so a lot of times people try and do
other stuff to get in or fit in and it's
like if you have just held up a little
longer your time would have came cuz
people going to get to your way
everybody everybody have their wave it's
it's it never fails think about it every
Market have their time I look at a guy
like uh you know even like um you know
shout outs to like a guy like peso p so
and and and and those guys like s Waka
it feel like his wave is like finally
kind of connecting on like a really big
level and he's been kind of in
independently like yeah yeah handling
business for so long and it feels like
he like he had the BET thing last year
like and it's like oh like finally
there's like a national Spotlight on
what he's been doing for so long so I
feel like Texas htown in general even
Dallas is going crazy a big ex to plug
is incredible yeah yeah um so it's just
dope to see Texas have like another just
new way it's naturally man from Houston
to Dallas they is just naturally
Hustlers you know um we definitely had a
Hustlers mentality we come from where we
used to slang stuff out the Trump yeah
on the regular you know and and also
with the Hustler mentality is we not
necessarily taking No for answer we
going to find a way to get in and fit in
however we can and when I say we I'm
speaking just for the Texas culture in
general for sure so yeah um when you
stay consistent you do things like that
it's definitely going to hit people
Radars and then when they hit their
Radars you know you take it and you you
you magnify and grow it and blow it up I
always wondered you've done so much for
your city I feel like when people think
of your city you're synonymous with it
at this point you're a community leader
at this point did you ever get unbanned
from the Box in Houston so it's crazy
you say in Houston bro I've been banned
I was never just banned in Houston it
was radio one yeah where why St that way
so Radio One the company they're still
the trade the truth band yeah mhm wow
well bro was there ever any has there
been any sort I mean look that was like
what over 10 years ago right like that
was so long ago it might have been
longer than that 14 years yeah it's been
so long like you would think people grow
people I I definitely grow I mean I I
haven't thought about them I don't I
don't I don't speak on them I don't I
just keep it moving you know I F my lane
and it works yeah and you know you're
also not an artist that necessarily
needs radio to be SU uccessful like
right you know and that's another reason
when I take time to salute a lot of the
the the Young Artists coming up they
created ways where radio isn't
necessarily even needed anymore for you
to to chart or for you to tour for you
to monetize you know what I'm say
support your family right right so I've
definitely it's a blessing I've I've
seen a lot of people come and go and I'm
still here and then when you think when
I actually did have radio I would
nowhere near as big as I am now that's
some real [__] that's some real [__]
yeah that's true yo when you do you ever
look back at like I you know I was I was
um just talking with uh my boy Amir
about kind of like the peak Grand Hustle
days shout out to Dro and and uh
obviously yourself and Bo was in the mix
and Iggy iselia was in the mix Travis
everybody Travis was in the mix it was
just such a crazy like RP um R you know
Tokyo there's a lot of us in there just
a crazy movement I mean before he got
you know aired out I mean I love the
alpha mea dude he had such a crazy voice
but do you ever look back at those days
and just like be like damn like that was
like a moment you know it feels like
sometimes we live and we're a part of
history but we don't know that we're
living in it at the time right and you
it probably actually if you was actually
in it you still would never see it the
way that the outside see it like the way
the world saw it right like for instance
me right right past the music like when
I come around whether it be the music or
just for me being on front line and
helping people people be amazed to me
I'm normal as can be it's just the
normal me so I don't I don't really
realize what I am to people you know
what I'm saying and even when you speak
of the hustle game on it
was had everybody talking about hustling
everybody wear Hustle Gang clothes
Hustle Gang everything you know what
saying to
where I think because we were living in
it it's kind of hard to see what
everybody else saw but we definitely
appreciate it because [__] you know that
that was at that time that everything
people was doing was Hustle Gang you
know for sure for sure I think back to
like the was it the Bett Awards when
like drama was DJing and just everybody
it was just a moment for sure man a
moment in that's why I was I was also
talking about it with drama I was like
bro how crazy was that yeah yeah shout
out to them you know they working on the
PSC album right now really pimp squad
click yeah they they back um I just left
from out there me and TI just shot the
video to the record SW I'm and I was out
there for his movie premiere make sure
everybody go check out the movie
departments um that's something dope
with a bunch of comedians I going say I
love to see TI like pivot and try to
just do whatever like he's just doing
what he wants at this point like if
you're a legend you can just do what you
want and I don't even think it's that we
do we want the thing it we just enjoying
life now that's what I was going to say
like to me
he's doing the the comedy [__] the right
way like he's like going to open mics
he's getting on the mic he's he's he's
you know it I feel like comedy and
Hip-Hop there's parallels like you got
to start somewhere you know what I'm
saying and I feel like he's doing it the
right way yeah his that movie um the
movie came out the pist like what was
the movie with a bunch of comedians back
in the day was that car wash there was a
lot of those movies car saying what what
a bunch of big comedians just say I
don't know about car wash I remember the
wash with Snoop and Dr Dre neither y was
somebody even way back then with Richard
Pride type yeah I was born in ' 87
so well yeah so yeah it's it's
definitely one of the ones that's going
to count um a this and that yeah and and
it's dope um even though it's Sun King
and that too but um I think we at a
point life man we just like that's the
reason why I did this album man we just
living like what's the point of waking
up angry every day or stress or running
to the same walls man we just got live
and enjoy life like my movie coming out
it's a comedy too oh you got a movie
coming yeah it drop it should drop any
day on Tu it's called Soul how's the
tuby game cuz I've I swear to God my
favorite thing to do is just search up
tuby on Twitter and just watch Clips so
you know it's two part look it's two
parts of it right you do have the
bootleg movies but they're great though
yeah but some of that [__] be just funny
I can justar I I I was telling him I was
like bro we got the cameras like we
should shoot like a white trash tuby
movie it it definitely would it
definitely would go but the other thing
people don't realize [__] tuby be having
better movies than Netflix and other
[__] they be having real they have like
official yeah a lot of official you know
what I'm saying yeah so that's the thing
people should definitely go cuz you know
the first thing they do is like what you
did they go look at Twitter they like
man I'm never downloading Tu but people
who don't know tu's free so if you have
a smart TV you're just in the game me
and then you know I have Partners like
um murder pain you know Chris and a lot
of them
um I believe t- Muller a lot of them you
know they took tuby to another level cuz
we didn't get familiar with tuby till we
start watching the show mgra or 211 or
um uh uh what was the other one love um
I don't know it's it's a lot of them
they got right now yeah tu's uh Tu
special oh plug love yeah and I I heard
that like they're really good like like
they pay well if you're you can they I
learned about tuby they say it was a man
who shot a whole video on the iPhone oh
I've seen ran it up bet when I say ran
up a bag ran it
up what are we doing shoot a movie come
on um you you mentioned TI you guys uh
this the guy who does these pranks where
he says shout out shout out white do mik
man I've been following we we bu me and
him building we built a relationship off
this so we I've been following this guy
for a long time and and I think he's
funny and cuz he does other stuff
besides just you know that and by the
way he does look really white yeah but
people don't know he's not he's not
that's what I'm saying I know he's not
but he looks really like even if
somebody took it the wrong way and he
tried to explain like no no no no this
is what my parents look like I don't
know if he can get that
far so that prank was real like your
guys' reaction was like real it wasn't
it looked a little set up if I'm being
honest what I will be honest with you
is it's way more that happened that day
before y'all got to see what y'all see
so we'll leave it at that okay
but you would be I would just say that
you would be like top five guy wouldn't
prank I put it like this it was a it was
a lot interesting that day and that was
realized that day yeah so we just leave
it at that man you know yeah okay that's
fair do mik he he good people though man
and I you know just I'm just see see cuz
we've been seeing some some of these
pranksters like I don't know if you saw
a couple weeks ago some dude got shot at
the mall it's all on yeah it's like yo
you got to be careful man people ain't
playing around these cuz you know like
the worst thing I can tell you now the
worst
thing with me would be if I'm with my
kids it ain't nothing nobody going to be
able to tell me nothing you know what
I'm saying it's like
so but I also gave him game too you know
like I told him hey man like this ain't
the all ways of going viral ain't good
and this isn't like a a sustainable
scalable way to do it like do it and
have a an audience and then then start
doing skits or then make a tub movie or
just start acting do you know I think
drei has done like such an incredible
job of like and his ass is funny with
the [__] that he I don't I don't know
how he wakes up with the thought
he has the most specific like scenario
videos that you just relate to and you
never yeah I'm saying like and you're
just like bro like the one with the
where he was playing the girls like who
are security guards at the front desk
and he's like chewing gum and like on
the
phonei my homie too man he's great but
he's done he's like built an in he's got
a sports agency like it's really crazy
it is see um I just did it was I did a
skit that just came out with me and Jack
funny M definitely should check Jack
funny out man on 313 he's super dope but
you know if you really pay attention
I've been in that world with a lot of
comedians already so I've been doing
I've been doing skits since Vine days
Vine was
lit before it was Tik Tock yeah did you
go to um The Comedy Mothership in
Austin that's Joe Rogan's Club his no no
no no no no no there's some dope
comedians out of Texas right now Ralph
Barbosa have you heard of him yeah I
just met him he's [__] hilarious um
uh another one live in Texas is it Matt
R yeah yeah he Liv to years he's lit
yeah um I think the last last time I was
in Austin for comedy was with Dave
Chappelle oh that's so yeah so I went to
Comedy Store once in uh Hollywood I go
to Comedy Store a lot but I went one
time and it was one of the times where
they were like hey everyone needs to
check their phone cuz Chappelle's about
to practice all his [__] tonight with no
like you had no idea so you like pay for
like a you know $25 ticket to just see
you know whoever they put on stage and
Dave Chappelle comes out lights up a
cigarette he did like two hours yeah he
always you know he he usually ends try
day for me with the comedy show it's
amazing so yeah yes now that's my
brother for real for real man and
um also it's big for him that like like
he uplift me like no other like he he be
proud like a big brother for just stuff
that I I do too you know what I'm saying
and stuff like that give you energy to
keep going I think like what he does is
so inspiring because he's like the
person who walked away from the biggest
show like the biggest sketch comedy
television show ever I think he had $30
million on the table and he's like nah
this don't feel right yeah one thing and
he got it right back he stands for what
he stands for and he just does what he
wants like if he don't feel like if he
don't feel good he ain't going to [__]
with it you know what I mean he
definitely more people should move that
way yeah yeah he's he's authentic like
money like money ain't everything you
know what I'm saying you know in this
day and age for some people it is for
people like us is it's not
worth jeopardizing your principles your
morals and your legacy you know mhm cuz
right now for for people like myself
Legacy is important the stuff that I do
in a community fighting that's all part
of my leg see my story my kids will be
able to to be proud of who they pops was
you know right right no for sure it's
crazy too because your legacy is like
cemented at this point and you've kind
of gone from like being like a guy if
you really weren't a like a Houston or
Texas hip-hop fan you just knew about
Trey because it was like the guy in Te
who runs Houston it's like the guy you
don't want to [__] with in Texas you
know what I'm saying um and like you
know fast forward 15 years you're like
very much a community leader you're very
much like when you think of like you
know when when I think of what you and
Mr Rogers were doing out there Shout Out
Mr Rogers um just crazy just like not a
lot of people would roll their sleeves
up and like actually do the work to like
help their neighbors I I'll tell people
or or also not just that by the way like
I've seen you post if some sort of
situation happens MH so we do a lot um
to touch on the stuff with Rogers like
people don't really realize the time
relief gang right yeah they don't
realize the time and everything that we
went through and dealt with you know
from Health to family to just we dealt
with a lot trying to do what we could do
for everybody you know
and that that's the part that that's
always going to be implanted in both me
and him but you know to the rest of
where they don't really they only see
what we showing that that was only 20%
of what we do you you see what I'm
saying like you got to think you're not
doing it for the wrong re we only doing
it when we show it we show for awareness
because it gets people more help and it
also plant seed to show people that they
can do things to help people you know
like it everybody think you got to be
millionaires to help people and that
ain't the case sometimes don't even take
money it may take the time or just the
ear you know and like nobody seeing of
sleeping in cars not being able to to
eat for days or or you know just
different stuff like it's a lot that
came with that man but we dedicated to
and even to this day I'm something
happen I'm one of the ones that's going
front I was going to say can you give us
like a random example cuz like I've seen
it a bunch like if there's a situation
where something bad happens to somebody
or you know there's an unfortunate thing
like you'll pull together your resources
you'll post about it you know can you
give me a situation in which you just
helped somebody that CU I I think some
people who don't really necessarily
follow you they know about what you guys
did in the hurricane but you guys do
stuff all the time for people oh man
it's it's too much to name um yo we got
to stop the interview again to tell you
about our folks at odd Soxs baby that's
right shout out to odd Soxs man the most
comfortable socks in the world they've
been riding with us since day one um and
let me tell you something man Christmas
time is is really sneaking up um
oddsocks official.com use the promo code
bootleg save 20% off at checkout they
got the crazy licenses check out these
Naruto socks [__] fire little
SpongeBob socks you know what I'm saying
how about this how about the how high
movie socks they got the
WWE they got the [__] Cheeto
socks you know what I'm saying shout out
to the [__] Cheeto socks they
just dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Ahad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Soxs Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet is really
what they are get them black white red
[__] tie-dye whatever you're into and
they got the underwear baby L Reese's
boys let's go odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg they got South
Park underwear too all the licenses WWE
scarf phas Breaking Bad South Park Power
Rangers Monopoly Coca-Cola they got it
all use that promo code bootleg and save
20% off at checkout also want to give a
shout out to our sponsor uh much love to
our good Folks at bluechew that's right
we talk about it all the time on the
podcast when you go to blue.com right
now you can get your first month for
free a lot of people ask well what is
blue and does it work well blue it has
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Calis the only difference is you don't
have to go to the doctor it's all online
you go to blue.com you get your [__]
handled over there and then they get you
handled by sending you a month for free
when you use the promo code bootleg
blu.com promo code bootleg try out blue
Chu it'll have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh bluee will have your
right like I said same active ingredient
as viagen Calis minus the awkward
doctor's appointment everything's online
and if you're asking well I don't know
man I just don't know try it out for
free for a month they'll send you a
month supply for free right to your
doorstep in discreet packaging blue
chewable form it's in a little it's a
little chewable man you take that thing
down and then you go to Pound Town take
your shorty to Pound Town goddamn it
blue chew.com use that promo code bootle
try for free for a month let's get back
to the interview they talked to me
earlier about Miss Martha which was the
77 year old lady they took to jail I
mean the lady they took to jail for $77
she was like 80 something years old y
you know we I got there for her um start
working to rebuild the house raised her
like 4050 ,000 um done a lot of
different stuff for her um you got that
um the man that they they showed me they
was trying to take his land in Texas
elder man went out there spoke up for
him um rip to the homie Canal I don't
know if you see the dude who he had less
than a few days to live he was on
hospice and I was saw him recently he
passed away right was one the Mexican
dude right yeah well no he's Indian oh
okay okay but I saw the food Community
Pages posted him and he just passed away
maybe two days ago right so when they
reached out I was one of his um one of
his favorite rappers I believe his
paage that we just give it 8 to 10,000
followers and um but then them his
biggest thing that he wanted was to be
able to get to the people and motivate
them you know to show people even with
him knowing his time was coming still be
grateful I just the the video that
really like was crazy to see was I I I
think it was a video he posted the day
before he passed or two days before he
passed and he was barely hanging on but
he was still very like yeah and I you
for me for me to take him
from to eight or 10,000 people being
able to see who he is to almost 200,000
in the matter a couple days help spread
his message Man spread his message like
no other you had people shout out to the
rock you had people everybody from all
across the world reaching out you know
what I'm saying
so it it's just so many different things
that I do you know you had the you had
the recent hurricanes and uh in the
Mississippi you know I'm I'm out the
front line with that it's just it's so
much different stuff that we do yeah for
sure yeah yeah then you know we still
fighting for Banna Taylor we still want
Justice for that um special [__] you to
Dani your Cameron and you know we still
going to keep it going yeah it's crazy
too because if you think about like you
know some of the activism that came out
of the
pandemic you know it felt at a at a
certain point in time like it was just
trendy for some people but you got to
but I'm but I let me finish my thought
what I was going to say was and then and
then you'll see people like cord day
you'll see people like my son people
like you like it's like yo this is not
just because it's popular to post a
black Square on Instagram or it's
popular to spread awareness cuz cuz
we're stuck in the house so so the thing
with that is people don't really
understand
again they only know what they see they
don't know our lives are at risk every
day I don't know if you know you know me
my
son right we moved yeah I'm going to get
to that too we we moved to Kentucky we
were living there wow so imagine being
followed by helicopters you you getting
random unmarked CS Following being shot
at whether it may be tear gas different
stuff um you know we've been we've been
through a lot man I'm talking about any
anything when anything can go the same
man Daniel Cameron just for us showing
up to his house had us arrested tried to
give us felonies but you can't do
nothing to the the officers that cold
blooded killed Banna Taylor crazy you
see what I'm saying like but I I I tell
people when it come to stuff like that
anytime we leave out the house [__] it's
not guaranteed we coming back that [__]
just as serious as the street life when
you dealing with going against crooked
officers the cops are biggest gang in
the and they what's crazy is police
literally move like a
gang I'm not going I'm not going I'm I'm
a realistic person I'm not going to
pending on all of them because even
times when we were arrested and stuff
like that you have officer Poli aside
like man I respect what y'all doing I
hate they got to be this way yeah I I
would say this like obviously most cops
are good but I just mean in terms of
like the culture of police there's
Unwritten laws that they had they follow
it is very much you know what so crazy
it be funny right like when people talk
talk about the streets and the industry
snitching right
mhm officers feel the same way if you go
tell on them that's what I was going to
say the same way like if a cop snitches
on another cop that cop's life yeah you
Outcast yeah so it's it's definitely the
same [__] it is definitely the same [__]
it is crazy I wonder um I I have you had
any sort of like cuz you feel like the
type of person who could run for office
and win never I I don't do politics have
you ever met with like you know you know
I've seen Killer Mike meet with um the
governor of uh Georgia who I know is
more of a conservative guy have you ever
tried to meet with the it's it's nothing
you really can do coming through Texas
and not know who I am so I came across
just about anybody it's been
times rather than even say their names
there been times some of the people at
the top of the ladder reached out to to
to talk or to try and come move move
through the town um and want me to pull
up and I just won't I just stand on
principles you know if it's something I
believe in cool if not no now what I do
now is I try and get people the
knowledge like I gave a lot of people
that know you can actually
be in jail and and vote you know what
I'm saying like it was just it was
different things that could be done and
then a lot of people you know their
mentality was like what I need to vote
for my vote don't count but when I start
helping them to understand
matters if you feel it count or
not the way we win is to get the right
people in office M you see what I'm
saying cuz if we ain't voting we letting
the people who going to [__] us over at
all times sit in office and whether they
run up money on and like Texas for for
whatever reason Texas has gotten a lot
closer in terms of it it's I know it's a
conservative state but it also is like a
state that I feel like a lot of people
are are are willing to look at other
ideas if you you go to a place like
Austin Austin is like a a a blue City
and a red State you know what I'm saying
like Austin kind of feels like it's its
own like it's its own like it's like you
go into a whole other place when you're
there man Austin is always it's that's
always been a lot of any of us from
Houston that's always been music-wise
one of our biggest fan bases um Love
Austin shout yellow rose Great
establishment as far as the industry
itself it's a dope place because they
love music I I look at Austin as when
you go to a lot of these festivals and
different stuff just certain people
walking around Barefoot and just smoking
hippie hippie life you know what I'm
saying of course you know they got the
streets I got family out there you know
I know that but it's just it's just a
good vibe City you know for sure man um
how much like obviously the album comes
out on the 20th right yeah yeah next
Friday um
how are you are you like going to stay
like pretty active with music or you
kind of going to put this out let it
live and then see how you feel as of now
I'm going
to stay active until I'm needed there's
the rejects yeah the reject yeah rejects
going to come to um and then after this
I'm going start I got over 2,000
unreleased records I'm going to start
letting records out I'm going start
letting the wild Factor record out you
see what I'm saying cuz one thing people
don't realize in the industry I probably
have the most powerful relationships
there is you're not going to you can't
find nobody who's been featured more or
has more features than me the closest
would be two chains you know what I'm
saying and I'm and I'm pretty sure
anybody tell you y like my relationships
is something way different man so I
think I'm going to get to a point where
I just start releasing a bunch of crazy
records for the fun of it yeah cuz why
sit on them man I'm sitting on 2,000
records plus so I I've been sitting on
them a long time that's crazy but I
don't I don't really I do it just for my
own personal M you know even though my
people say it's selfish but just do it
for my own personal is it like huh like
when you go to the studio theraputic
that's that's that's my go-to you know I
don't smoke or drink that's that's my
go-to but um Not only would it being my
uh my goto is
like when it come times with situations
going on I have to pick be there for the
people or focus on myself and I
always you know what I'm saying I always
pick the people so I never really get to
get the fair shot this is the first time
nothing's really fully interrupted me
from trying to push a put an album out
so I'm just living it while I can to
next [__] hitting I got to get back to
it yo is Texas open carry yeah yeah yeah
yeah do do you cuz you know like we're
in California where they make it
extremely difficult to like protect
yourself and uh you know there's good
things in bad things about that
obviously there there's a terrible
school shooting that happened in Texas
in all day I was there that's see that
you know I'm front line all that that
was a heartbreaking situation yeah yeah
may they rest in peace man um I am like
typically a liberal guy but I do feel
like our our countryes mov so past like
ever changing the gun culture this is
just who we are like we are the United
States like I think that there should be
like obvious um background checks like
very common sense things but I just
wonder for you like do you feel like in
Texas certain [__] doesn't happen as
often because people think twice about
so it's the GI and the curse right is
the giv and the curse people think twice
one cuz [__] the person you thinking of
going may have exactly what you have so
you you're not really trying to right
feel that you know what I'm saying you
you you have that but then it's
like the curse is damn you EMP power
some of the the goofies that just do
stupid [__] that don't stand on
principle or nothing and B and
accidentally hurt a child or something
else so you know it's the it's the gift
and a curse with it man which is like
it's almost like here like the gift in
the curse of California is like you know
there's not as much like I guess it's
not as easy to just go to a Walmart and
buy AR-15 and go shoot up a [__] your
workplace or a school it's very hard to
to do that the curse is you might get
ran up on and there really like like
it's active I'm sure you've seen the
smash and grabs and people in the bay
get bipped every [__] day like it's
it's wild like so it's kind of like it's
kind of like you got to pick your poys
in a little bit and it's unfortunate but
this is America cuz you ain't never
going to get rid of the guns no no no
matter what there's too many of them too
much big business no man
but believe it or not you just you have
to I've learned to ADT to my environment
but I'm going to tell you one thing that
really really got to me right I was one
day cuz I like my son Houston you know
he's um
13 I expose him to the game yeah like I
he's he's going to have both smarts he
can be a square and a street kid at the
same time just so he'll
know what to do what not to do and if I
expose it to him no child can come key
him up and excite him to go do no crash
dummy [__] cuz it pops and already show
y so um I was like man you know what
[__] it let's let's just go to the gun
range right but in my mind like damn I
don't want people sitting here whining
cuz he young man I went in there it was
kids seven to 8 years old all the way up
this the um this place super pack yeah
but my point of saying that is people
are already preparing to and they're
already adapting to their their
environment and and you never know I
mean sh getting it can get real and the
world is getting real right now in
general yeah now I I twister does a a
good job in uh Chicago He classes so you
know it's crazy I told him he going to
have to come I I told him we were well
we ended up doing trade day so we didn't
get around to it then I just had my
listening part in Chicago he came out um
shout out to him Raul but yeah I told
him yeah he going to have to train me to
make sure I can be a sharpshooter I'm
I'm going to take some time yeah he's
really good at like he's training like
people how to properly own a weapon how
to like like you know what I'm saying
like cuz at the end of the day like
that's something that I think in the
black community isn't taught you know
what I'm saying you got to realize man
[__] from where we come from back in the
G we used to think to whole a gun
sideway that you not hitting none of we
used to think it was Goofy for people to
be like that but [__] no that's you got
to have your aim yeah yeah so yeah and a
lot of people's lives probably got saved
because it was held the wrong way to be
that too yeah yeah that's what's up B
hey um it's crazy because uh so I was uh
I was in Vegas I got to hang out with
James Harden your guys's new coach was
there he made yoka who I'm sure just
shout out to him man he's a legend you
know what I'm saying he's a real uh he's
a real uh he's a legend you know what I
mean uh Harden is like there was rumors
of him coming back to Houston I hope so
I don't think it's going to happen but
how like James Harden is like about as
Houston as you can get he's the time
that's my brother his weekend just
passed um and you know even with a lot
of stuff I do in the community he jumped
side by side with me you know him his
whole team you know super solid dude um
his whole Foundation all the way from
poo to everybody you know they all hands
on man so dope and you know it's his
Club there a lot of his businesses there
when like uh like like I always wonder
like I saw the kid Thompson who got
drafted by you guys this year I don't
know if he even know knows who you are
cuz he's a literal child I think he's
from the bay mostly but I wonder like if
I'm if I got drafted to the Rockets the
first thing I would do is DM I would DM
Trey I like hey man they don't even
necessarily have to right because my
relationship so strong with the rockets
and and the Asos and stuff like that I
literally pull up did you guys are you
guys did you guys advance to the next
round Astros yeah of course final four
my diamond backs are in there we right
now we we F to play Texas oh yeah it's
like a civil war yeah yeah but Dallas
versus Houston yeah you know man Astros
to the end man even though you know they
they went they went through they phase
of people hating on the low but at the
end of the day they came back and showed
it was pure greatness was it hard for
people from Houston to adopt the Texans
as their
team I mean what you mean I just feel
like you know anytime there's like an
expansion team even like here right like
the Chargers are La no one gives a [__]
about the Chargers in La like they just
don't care right the Oilers left then
there's the Cowboys who are like just
everyone's team you know are are you a
Texans or a Cowboys guy man I'm always
been I RI my city with so you were an
Oilers guy definitely was an Oiler guy
shout to Warren Moon Eddie Geor crazy
like my father die hard Cowboys fan of
course he is you see what I'm saying so
I me myself I just i r the eight to the
fullest I rep but see when I if it's
it's either Houston or Texas so anything
coming out of that I'm always going
stand have you uh have you met CJ stad
yet yeah yeah I was just with him I was
with him at uh yo what up guys we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie it's winning season
right now NFL we're in the thick of it
I've been doing really good on my NFL
bets by the way plus NBA officially back
we got playoff baseball it's going crazy
especially if you like to throw down
some of that money and do little
gambling you got to head over to my
bookie uh this what's dope about my
bookie it doesn't matter if your team
sucks my team the Cardinals they're
trash don't matter I'm still winning on
Sundays baby all right at my bookie all
right you can use my bookie for your
daily odd boost same game parlays and
take advantage of the crazy huge prize
pool contest plus right now my bookie
has a no strings attached that's the
important thing no strings attached cash
bonus that let you deposit and withdraw
quick that's free cash no strings
attached deposit take it out and then go
about your day or get in on some of this
NFL and NBA action baby all right just
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up go to mybookie.ag use the promo code
bootleg on your first deposit and you'll
receive up to $200 in cash what are we
talking about no strings attached what
my bookie use the promo code bootleg all
right maybe you want to gamble on some
NFL maybe you want to get in on some of
this early NBA action maybe you want to
get in on some of this playoff baseball
it's really on you use the promo code
bootleg and receive up to $200 in cash
that's right try my bookie right now use
that promo code bootleg and you can grab
um how about this man there's some crazy
odds going on and I like this one cuz
what you can do is you can throw down on
a potential Super Bowl front runner and
uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus
38,000 if you put
$100 you win
$338,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie
plus we got to give a big shout out to
our family at King pom man we love King
pom over here on the bootle C podcast
this is what's great about King pom
first of all it's all about that organic
no tobacco leaf this thing right here is
a boy look at that that's just a leaf
right there King pal they got everything
you need man they got these cones with
the squeezing pop tpin in them the
flavors this right here is the uh the
dragon fruit we got the grape HD the
watermelon wave so many flavors what's
dope about King pal if you're in
whatever City you're in you could find
King pom at your local smoke shop your
local 7-Eleven all right I'm telling you
King pom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke what you're
smoking all right you stuff one of these
boys up with some flour uh and and you
just you're Off to the Races I'm telling
you you hit the tip you get hit with
that flavor and it's man it's nothing
like it the squeeze and pop on King
palom is insane all right and they got
all siiz cones all right so go to King
pom man organic tobacco-free leaves of
all sizes like this is a this is a this
is look look look we're talking about
all sizes here what are we talking about
what are we talking about here boys all
right go to King pom.com right now you
go order whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ash trays they got
damn all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview with Snoop and
whiz and then I was with him he is
balling yeah he is he just broke um he's
breaking records yeah yeah I don't think
he's throwing an interception yet it's
been like five games yeah yeah you know
definitely D for greatness yeah do you
ever cuz I was like uh you know I own a
club now in a and um I'm like conflicted
cuz I'm a a hardcore Phoenix Suns fan
and some of our biggest customers are
Suns and sometimes they come in on
nights that I'm like as a fan like but
there's a game tomorrow yeah like bro
you need I
I party too hard in my opinion and I
always tell this to people like
obviously I think Atlanta gets uh the
credit for being the strip club City I
personally think Houston is the best
strip club city in the country right now
we definitely you guys got the Bob thing
going on we the place right now that
everybody come to yes every we is what
people look at as the Party City right
now like if you want to go have a good
time great food yeah yeah definitely I
I've learned that we the the culture
definitely and a lot of people like
sneaky live there that people don't know
live there that that too I've talked to
so many artists like oh I'm living in
Houston I'm like really can tell you A
lot of them that yeah tons of them yeah
yeah of course I wouldn't say it on here
but course of course there's like like I
was talking to BFB the Pacman and he was
like I'm been living in Houston I mean
this is on camera so I can talk about
but like a lot of people love Houston
man yeah yeah yeah you get the good
Mexican food not quite as the West Coast
but you get some good Mexican this is
the third you get barbecue this is the
third damn time cuz I was on ad Park
last night and I said Texas Mexican food
is definitely better than out here n you
guys got barbecue though have you have
you ate Mexican food in Texas so much
you got to come with us then I've gone
with give me you give me a restaurant
right now I'm going make sure I go to
before I leave texx is cool Tex Max is
cool see we ain't even talking about we
not even going to call it txx no no no
they no they have like real Mexican
spots there
like you give me a restaurant here I'm
going take my ass there and I'm we for
sure going to find out you know what it
is is I always say if I rank the best
Mexican food it's San Diego cuz it's
right there the border is right there
okay proximity of course yeah El Paso's
got good Mexican food cuz of course
proximity it's right wat is right there
I was just look at proximity right the
thing about San Diego is they got all
the ill Mexican food and they got the
ill MOS so you get all the like the SE
food [__] the shrimp cocktail and then
LA's just got the best taco trucks in
the game I got and then Arizona then
Texas [__]
no y yall not even going to do Texas
like that we ain't letting that happen
you going I'm you need to come to Texas
with us then we going to go on that in
the bus I'm supposed to um have you gone
hog hunting out there yet so I did you
know the it's crazy I took me and my son
and I just didn't post it cuz you never
know because is it is a pretty intense
uh video I've seen the videos of the
guys on the helicopter just mowing down
pigs yeah no we got in the trenches with
them it wasn't that we in the middle of
the night in the pits black did you stab
any huh did you nah no we a have to do
that I'm going to I'm going to show you
I just never you know I never post so I
got invited to go to Texas with OT and
he said baby we going to go hog hunted
baby and he's like we're going to be in
the back of a truck with a machine gun
just mowing down pigs and I'm a huge
animal lover but I don't love him enough
not to eat them obviously I wouldn't eat
I wouldn't dare eating no goddamn hog me
I'll eat the swine the swine is divine I
mean not that type of hog we talking
about wild boyss you a you don't want to
eat that see but then I I I I understand
why they want you to kill the Hogs cuz
they are an invasive species in Texas
for people don't know they [__] up crops
they kill uh pets they they're just
they're just not the nicest pigs but
they're also the literal pig that Pumba
is in The Lion King so you know I'm
going to end up going and just murdering
a bunch of pumbas in the middle of I
don't want to look at it like that but
if you ever get caught in the vicinity
with one of them you [__] are they mean
are they nice so maybe they got they
probably got one of the most vicious
bites you going you know what maybe that
is um the more dangerous way I'm going
to approach this but it'll make me sleep
at night better so I don't feel like a
murderer is I'm going to just get out of
the truck and I'm going to wait for them
to come at me and then I'm going to kill
them oh it's not going to be there and
they fast as [__] so we out there we
have to use night vision to see him from
a distance wow I've seen the videos
listen I've seen the Tik toks they're
it's crazy that's the next Vlog we're
doing we're going to
Texas oh wow that is a look at that
Pig's teeth
bro do do you um stuffed that and
hanging on the wall at home hell no
uh-uh you see me I'm going to take one
of them and I'm going to put it on the
podcast
set we're going to do the
Taxidermy hey you do know they com in
peex so you it can be there's a bunch
yeah that's you in trouble if you don't
know what you're doing or you ain't out
there with the right people you [__]
what yeah I mean do is is it a thing you
could inform me do people pay to go hunt
him I don't know you know uh people get
paid to go hunt them because so we can
make money yeah because that's why so
the people who go up in the helicopters
they definitely get paid the people who
take people out you know what I'm saying
because it's they so much of a problem
yeah I've heard that they're really bad
for the you know environment and but
they're also like you know little very
little all right trying to P one to tell
me that my friend has a pig yeah but but
that kind of not a boy no he's got a pig
like a little uh Pig's dope but boore so
not a boar yeah boar is not to be played
with that'd be a pretty sick if you're
actually you won't even be able to put a
boy down with a handgun like that
notless well I so so I had heard uh I
was talking with uh ot's pops and he was
saying that sometimes you got to shoot
it and then you got to slice it from
behind which to me sounds like something
I'm just not willing to do yeah I ain't
got that close to it I'm good I don't
want to ever stab anything unless I have
to yeah definitely if you got to protect
the family if you have to you're going
to stab somebody yeah but I'm not going
to do it like just for the [__] cuz it's
Monday like it's Monday let's go [__]
slice some Pig's throats out here um all
right so the new album is uh Stuck In
Motion Stuck In Motion 18 tracks 18
tracks it's your first album in a while
yeah I think it's what been five years
as far as a real album yeah it's been
it's been a minute you know I threw out
songs and little tapes and stuff but no
this is and even when I threw out tapes
it kind of got lost in the shuffle cuz
the game and we dealing with life yeah
but this is the first real album that
I'm actually you know crazy thing as
much as y'all know me and I'll be around
y'all I don't really do interviews yeah
you don't do a lot you see what I'm
saying so when I when you see me talking
doing that then it's it's that time it's
time you're on you're on you're on the
campaign yeah yeah definitely there it
is man well listen go get the album go
support it go buy a a bump box they're
incredible always bumbox docomo X's make
sure y'all go get that they're amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh if you break
a cord though you're [__] cuz I so the
thing is they just got to reach out to
us a lot of people do that and once they
lose a cord they' be like man my box
ain't working like if you didn't give me
the opportunity know I could I there was
so I you you had given me like when me
and head interviewed you a while ago I
think Jeezy came up to the station at
the same time when I had my daughter
with me yeah you had your daughter with
you you had given me like a small like
one of the smaller ones right and um the
cord went out so I tried to buy that
cord on Amazon I I bought like three
different cords and none of them would
keep this thing on yeah and I called
when you guys open the store I was like
oh this is great this isn't too far I
called the [__] store I said hey guys
I got this model uh can I just go up
there and buy a cord and they're like
nah we don't sell just the cord and I
was like well [__] I don't know why the
[__] you didn't just call me cuz I you
know I I did call you and then you just
sent me a whole new bump box that's the
easy way too yeah so that's when I got
the big doggy style one and doggy style
is my favorite hip-hop album ever oh
yeah well top three you know at any
given day it could be number one so
doggy style was a classic for sure um
but yeah so go get a bump box they're
incredible and a slapstick yeah yeah and
some headphones and by the way the
headphones sound amazing I mean the ones
I have are probably four or five years
old at this point but they sound [__]
great they're the on people didn't know
so you know it's crazy people didn't
really realize how dope they were now
everybody trying to get them when we
don't have them cuz at the time there
was like those beat studios and yours
sounded way better because those were
the ones I was I was using at the radio
but then I got the ones from you and
they sounded [__] way better yeah and
you know once we were out everybody like
[__] man we need to get that and that's
it's like it's too late but but the in
ear is the way to go that's what
everyone's doing and the thing is with
me being in music my partner Rob and and
everybody over there it's like we always
going to make sure our [__] louder more
basic more clear yeah so that's the
thing we go for you know we not trying
we're not trying to hit a quick lick for
sure yeah yeah so no for sure the N is
going to kill um my glass is coming out
with um Habibi glasses that's going to
be
crazy um the movie the cartoon movie
coming me and Mazy still got a movie
unreleased in the whole I saw your post
with yeah yeah we you guys got a whole
album together yeah we already had one
out we got a second one just sitting up
wait how long ago did you guys put that
out like 2016 a while yeah yeah cuz for
people who don't know Mazy has albums
out with artists that you you before you
even like cuz I I really the first time
I interviewed Mazy was 2017 and I think
he had the [__] with you he had the [__]
with Gunplay out he's just got a bunch
of collab album that's my little brother
for real for real like he's the best our
relationship is it ain't even really
about the music for sure and then you
know I'm just a big bro to him so we
were talking about it last night he said
I'm probably one of the only people that
that put pressure on them when it's time
to work cuz I'm a I'm I'm a monster and
he's like one of the coldest rappers
period yeah yeah so you know that that
that's dope man but yeah we got the
movie we still got another album
um that album I still got a I still have
a album sitting up that never released
with Thug I have one sitting up with
Conway one with uh Dave
East
um who else um just sitting on on a hard
drive you and Conway have a whole album
yeah and this the [__] Dam no super J
what are you waiting for the thing is I
make timeless music it don't got to come
out today it'll come out and still shake
some [__] up have you talked to uh Thug
or had any communication with him since
he's been away you know I've been the
court I just went to visit him probably
less than a month or two ago how's he
doing he good man I think the the the
main thing is keeping faith but just
going through the process the process is
the hard part bro cuz even with me in
life right now right nobody wants to go
through the process cuz that's the most
frustrating
and that's what's building us for growth
for whatever's about to come for us so
but Spirit wise yeah he was he was cool
yeah he was chilling yeah uhhuh
definitely you know um I think people
don't understand it's I think some
people are thinking it's a federal Reco
not it's it's a state Rico yeah it's a
state you know it's still it's just
disappointing it's still serious yeah
serious it's just disappointing
because I know his heart I know him for
real for real like I know he only try to
help everybody you know what I'm saying
and but in life that's what a lot of us
get the ones who tend to try and help a
lot you know it tend to backfire
backfire on us at times but I feel they
going to be all right man and you know
the other thing
is it's a blessing at the same time
because now guess what God didn't
Expos things and people who shouldn't
have been around you so now when you
come home it's strictly focused on your
family your kids and those who really
[__] with you yeah it seems like almost
everybody folded around him
unfortunately a lot of people yeah I
just feel like you know it's not my
situation to speak on more I'm I'm a
roll with whatever he rolling with but
um definitely it it hurt to see him just
have to just sit there and everybody
else just doing what they do yeah that's
that's what I always say about that the
situation obviously is until I hear how
Thug feels about you know certain things
that's you know that's ultimately going
to be it he he's going to have the final
say so with that you know right so I
mean yeah that makes sense yeah well
listen man go get the album when it
drops Friday um this will come out
probably next Wednesday so couple days
from now the album will be out go
support it uh and yeah man you always
got something cooking yeah I'm up to
something man I up to something yeah
there it is trade the truth appreciate
you brother let's get it yes sir fire
what's going on man I want to shout out
to to our family a hardine for
presenting to you another interview all
right there's another interview coming
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day shout out to harden though if you're
in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to harden in
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they will get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg cev
show you say hey Harden I heard about
y'all on the bootleg cev podcast they're
gonna take care of y'all all right so go
follow him Hardin Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
vegas.com what's up Hardin